[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 78 l'émission ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce à magazine football voisin
recevait bûcher loi ce week-end et les
visions l'ont emporté 1 0 sur leur
pelouse retour sur cette rencontre dans
ce magazine jeux olympiques 2000 24 tv
70 2 vous propose aujourd'hui un coup de
projecteur sur la cérémonie d'ouverture
des milliers de personnes pourront voir
le spectacle sur la scène une première
dans l'histoire des jeux modernes foot
us zoom aujourd'hui sur les templiers
d'elancourt le club est actuellement en
deuxième division et ils le montrent et
l'année prochaine en élite ce sera notre
module découverte l'actualité sportive
c'est maintenant sur tb 78
mais avant de développer ces titres on a
parlé un box ce devait être l'un des
tournants de la carrière de tony yoka le
boxeur originaire de chanteloup les
vignes ne défiera pas le croate filip
hrgovic pour une demi finale ibm des
lourds en mars la raison tony yoka ne
seraient pas libres pour disputer son
combat car il a un contrat déjà signé
avec le congolais va coller un
adversaire qu'il aurait dû affronter en
janvier à paris bercy mais le rendez
vous avait été reportée en mars suite à
l'épidémie de covin 19 la fédération ibm
basée aux états unis a donc tranché et
tony yoka ne pourra pas affronter et
hrgovic une vraie déception pour
l'illinois qui devra encore patienter
pour pouvoir a disputé deux gros combat
en vue d'un titre de champion du monde
une autre déception mais cette fois ci
en tennis l'yvelinois rinderknecht chez
passer du rire aux larmes à l'open
d'australie le français de 26 ans a tout
d'abord remporté mardi dernier une
splendide victoire en cinq sets contre
le local pop irene au premier tour le
score 7-5 4-6 6-2 3-6 6-3 un match très
sulfureux dans une ambiance bouillante
avec un public hostile un match qui a eu
un impact sur l'état physique du saint
germanois de 26 ans il n'a pas réussi à
s'aligner sur le deuxième tour forfait
car blessé au poignet il n'a pas jeu
contre le britannique dan evans arthur
are in darkness reste tout de même à la
48e place mondiale le meilleur
classement de sa carrière un mot de
football à présent et plus précisément
de mercato ça bouge encore à versailles
après la signature de capot silva en
provenance de poissy le club de la cité
royale enregistre l'arrivée de
l'attaquant du stade laval johan brun le
joueur de 27 ans a notamment joué en
ligue 2 à grenoble il portera le numéro
14 il jouera ce samedi à 16h15 le
huitième de finale de coupe de france
contre toulouse
toujours en football dans le championnat
de première division de district voisins
le bretonneux qui vise la montée a
réalisé la bonne opération du week-end
en dominant bûcher loi sur sa pelouse le
résumé du match des images de céline
chat
un match pour croire à la montée le
voisin fc recevait laisse bûcher l'oise
ce dimanche 23 janvier l'ebit sinois
ultra dominateur sur la première période
dont s'ouvrir le score sur cette action
mais le but est refusé pour un hors jeu
peu évident un second but sera également
invalidé quelques minutes plus tard
après 45 minutes les deux prétendants
aux premières places letra lise 0 à 0
ils sont 38 ans et je maîtrise totale ou
déjà reparti relation prend 4 000 c'est
flatteur pour moi parce qu'ils sont
quand à 0 5 0 et enfin c'est logique
alors la première mi temps on a on a
fait une très bonne première mi temps
avec pas mal d'occasions on a beaucoup
garder le ballon
on leur a fait très très mal beaucoup
s'étaient beaucoup retard ils ont fait
beaucoup de fois on retour des
vestiaires même scénario voisins le
bretonneux poussé arrive finalement à
trouver le chemin des filets
cette fois ci le but est bien accorder
les joueurs locaux réussissent à tenir
ce score jusqu'à la fin 1 0 score final
on a réattaqué fort on met ce but au
bout de au bout d'un quart d'heure à peu
près après plusieurs buts refusés donc
un but qui nous fait du bien et on a
maîtrisé dans l'ensemble on a fait un
bon match dans les attitudes dans les
duels et puis on a réussi à garder score
surtout
lui reparti sur le dessus après juste
après ce but la 60e minute je crois il
ya une section pour finir les matches on
a des occasions de marquer pour égaliser
mais
résultat logique au classement bûcher
l'oise est désormais 5e voisins le
bretonneux et 2e et reste au contact du
chéné leader de la division prochaine
journée le dimanche 30 janvier
on continue notre tour d'horizon des
résultats sportifs du week-end dans le
département et que notre journaliste
bixente mérian centriste evans qui est
avec nous sur ce plateau pour soir par
michaël alors racontez nous un petit peu
la suite pour la première division de
district oui parce qu'on a nos actes eux
m'en viens de voir voisin qui prend donc
la 2e place du championnat mais devant
il y a le chesnais qui est allé battre
epône sur sa pelouse de buzeins
troisième du championnat l'équipe
réserve de houille était en
démonstration à la maison contre
aubergenville dernier du championnat
score sans appel 7 0 pour les autres
résultats va les 78 dollars siens
partout tout comme bailly noisy contre
sartrouville et comme chaque semaine un
petit mot le national 2 vous parlait il
ya quelques instants de johan brun la
nouvelle recrue du versailles 78 il
était sur le banc ce week-end et sa
nouvelle équipe a obtenu le point du nul
ce week-end sur le terrain de son
dauphin l'équipe réserve de lorient
score final un but partout un nul qui
permet donc aux versailles et de
conserver la tête du championnat et leur
avance sur leurs 3e et concurrents les
voltigeurs de châteaubriant qui ont
aussi fait match nul oui parce qu'on le
rappelle un l'équipe b de lorient ne
peut pas monter un c'est ça c'est les
règles en france en fait les équipes
réserves ne peuvent pas dépasser la
nationale 2 donc même si lorient termine
premier ils ne pourront pas monter c'est
un concurrent de moins pour versailles
sachant qu'une seule place est à prendre
est synonyme de promotion en national on
passe rugby à présent oui la mauvaise
opération pour plaisir en fédérale 2 qui
perd à domicile contre le havre 30 à 40
les plaisirs war est à distance des
barrages et pour la montée les cinq
premiers sont un peu loin mais il reste
une sixième place à prendre elle est
occupée par le club du rheu et justement
il se trouve que le week-end prochain
plaisir se rendra en bretagne sur la
pelouse du club dur justement pour un
match décisif et biais pour bien amorcer
la deuxième partie de saison du rugby
encore et de la coupe d'europe puisque
on suit un joli minois qui performent
bixente au bar et le jeune prodige du
stade français a largement contribué à
la victoire des siens ce dimanche contre
connacht aligné dans le quinze d'entrée
de jeu il a participé à un scénario
d'anthologie le stade français était
obligé de s'imposer avec six points
d'écart au minimum et le bonus offensif
mené 20 à 31 alors qu'il ne restait que
13 minutes de jeu michaël les parisiens
ont mis le feu à la fin de match et
l'ont emporté 37 31 pile poil pour race
et la pile poil pour se qualifier en
huitièmes de finale la championne cap du
coup les au bar et a été précieux dans
le jeu et aurait même pu ajouter un
essai au compteur à la 35e il aplatit
dans l'en but mais voit son essai refusé
pour une faute de son coéquipier tôle ou
la toux on pourra le retrouver face au
racing 92 le 6 avril et avant ça au
tournoi des six nations u 19 avec un
autre yvelinois elle joue ben légal fort
mosquée rugby évoluant maintenant au
racing à 92 du handball maintenant
affiche une société la reprise pour les
féminines de montigny le bretonneux
premier match de l'année et première
défaite le score 28 à 31 contre plouagat
ça commence à devenir inquiétant pour
les inhumant ten qui se rapproche de la
fin de tableau avec un bilan de 3
victoires 1 nul et 6 défaites et on
termine par de la course entre elles une
édition anniversaire pour le raid 28 qui
fêtait justement son 28ème anniversaire
donc un moment un peu particulier pour
les 450 participants au départ donc de
plusieurs trail 12 28 45 et 70 km le
principe une course d'orientation par
équipe de 3 ou 5 avec des jeux et le
ramassage de balises de différentes
couleurs à l'arrivée le classement se
fait selon le temps et les bonifications
entraînée par les balises trouvé la
course historique c'est bien entendu
celle des 70 km qui part d'epernon et
arrive à bures-sur-yvette essonne avec
une bonne partie dans la forêt de
rambouillet pour le 28 km le départ se
faisait à rambouillet justement des
parcours avec quelques passages infos
insolites comme vous avez pu le voir sur
les photos prises par vincent krieger et
on dit bravo à tous les participants me
canis courageux participants merci
bixente pour toutes ces précisions vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine on va
maintenant prendre la direction de
montigny le bretonneux une compétition
départementale était organisée ce
week-end au complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin une première depuis deux ans
des images de céline charles
c'est une grande première depuis deux
ans monti le bretonneux la ville
organisait une compétition
départementale ce samedi 22 et dimanche
3 janvier au complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin on a vainement attendu par
tout le club local pendant deux ans on
en a pas fait donc j'ai été le dernier à
faire en 2019 et je suis un mois le
premier à refaire en 2022 donc j'ai fait
la dernière et je refais la première ça
fait deux ans les filles jouent bien je
qu'est-ce qu'on est toujours en
protocole sanitaire donc port du masque
obligatoire juste quand elles passent
pas et elles peuvent lui enlever ou
sinon tout le monde joue le jeu
j'ai ça ça se passe plutôt bien
[Musique]
au total plus de 400 sportifs venus
d'une vingtaine de clubs du département
avaient fait le déplacement pour renouer
avec la compétition
suit à ses contacts sur gmail organiser
un
une production parce que sa première
depuis deux ans donc cette ambiance
c'est vrai que ça nous a manqué à tous
donc
ja se contente de
organiser ça donc aujourd'hui c'était
s'ils continuent comme idée pas vraiment
de reprendre
prochain rendez-vous à monti le
bretonneux au mois de mars pour les
championnats interdépartementaux
[Applaudissements]
la semaine olympique et paralympique
s'est ouvert ce lundi lors rendez-vous
célèbre les jo de paris à 2024 qui se
tiendront dans très exactement 9 114
jours et chaque mois grégory canal et
vient nous parler de l'événement dans ce
set 8 sport bonsoir grégory saint michel
les organisateurs ont confirmé en
décembre ce qui était un secret de
polichinelle un cérémonie d'ouverture de
paris 2024 se déroulera bien sûr la
scène le 26 juillet 2024 oui ce n'était
pas une surprise tony estanguet le
président du comité d'organisation a
parlait déjà il ya un an l'été dernier
aux jeux de tokyo emmanuel macron avait
même confirmé cette ambition l'idée
serait née lors des jeux olympiques de
la jeunesse de buenos aires en 2018
d'après thomas ce bar le président du
cio le comité international olympique la
cérémonie d'ouverture avait été célébré
à l'époque autour de l'obélisque symbole
de la ville et a été une grande réussite
populaire pour paris les organisateurs
ont donc sorti le grand jeu en plaçant
la scène comme décor principal de
l'événement et ce sera une grande
première et j'avais une cérémonie
d'ouverture des jeux olympiques d'été ne
s'était déroulée hors d'un stade paris
souhaite rompre avec la tradition et des
précédentes éditions l'objectif c'est de
mettre en avant l'histoire de france ce
patrimoine sa créativité son audace
rappelons tout de même que c'est la
france qui est le berceau est de
l'olympisme moderne avec pierre de
coubertin et la france a apporté
d'ailleurs son lot d'évolutions première
participation des femmes en 1900 premier
village olympique en 1924 première
mascotte aux jeux d'hiver de grenoble en
1968 autre grande nouveauté on revient
en 2024 la cérémonie elle débutera par
le défilé des athlètes qui assisteront
et participeront au spectacle 10500
sportif et 206 délégations
internationales qui prendront place sur
160 bateaux enfin au rayon des premières
également le rendez-vous proposera des
accès gratuit aux spectateurs à quoi
ressemblera ce défilé et grégory
qu'ayant premier des jeunes qu'elle un
show de cette heure rien que ça la
cérémonie a débuté à du pont
d'austerlitz à devant le jardin des
plantes pour un défilé fluvial d'est
vers l'ouest 2 6 km la déambulation
passera devant quelques grands monuments
notre-dame la conciergerie le loup le
musée d'orsay sans oublier la tour
eiffel bien sûr et des sites officiels
aussi des jo de la place de la concorde
à l'esplanade des invalides
le grand palais et le pont d'iéna les
embarcations navigueront sous 8 à 10
points ou des spectacles se dérouleront
danseurs sur les toits orchestre
flottant hologramme drones seront au
programme des festivités et la cérémonie
se terminera au trocadéro sera installée
la tribune officielle garni de 120 chefs
d'état pour le grand final avec
l'allumage de la flamme olympique est
quand même personnes seront attendues et
grégory un côté des organisateurs on
table sur un minimum de six cent mille
spectateurs soit dix fois plus que dans
un stade traditionnelle sur les quais
hauts ils pourront d'ailleurs profiter
d'accès gratuit sur les quais bas en
revanche entre le pont d'austerlitz et
le pont d'iéna les places seront
payantes 80 écrans géants répartis dans
toute la ville ils seront également
sonorisé permettront de suivre cette
cérémonie partout dans la capitale à la
diffusion télévisée n'est également pas
oublier on parle d'un milliard de
téléspectateurs tout de même michael
avec un dispositif novateur et notamment
la présence de caméras embarquées sur
les bateaux pour être au plus près des
athlètes quelles sont les prochaines
étapes et bien chiffre est tout d'abord
le coût d'une telle cérémonie avec un le
montant d'une facture qui sera forcément
élevé qui sera connu fin 2022 elle sera
financée sur le fond sur les fonds des
organisateurs à 97% privé et enfin s'est
affiné aussi avec les pouvoirs publics
et les autorités fluviales le dispositif
de sécurité qui on l'imaginé sera
centrale dans cet événement sur le
papier en tout cas mickaël ça donne
envie et on donne rendez-vous bien sûr
au 26 juillet 2024 merci à grégory pour
votre chronique sur les jeux olympiques
de 2024 on a déjà dit est rare il faut
le dire un grégorien on y sera lancement
ni sera bien sûr je vous propose
maintenant le découvrir l'une des
équipes phares du département des
yvelines les templiers d'elancourt le
club est aujourd'hui en deuxième
division de football américain mais
aspire à remonter cette année en élite
regardez notre module découverte
[Musique]
aujourd'hui une seule sur les terrains
de football américain pour rencontrer
les templiers d'elancourt l'une des
meilleures équipes de deuxième division
[Musique]
pour commencer à ce module jérémy état
mais à côté alors jérémy qui a passé une
vingtaine ou trentaine d'années
quasiment aux templiers d'elancourt vous
êtes un petit peu la mémoire du club est
ce que ce club est l'un des plus grands
clubs de france
les templiers c'est un grand club c'est
un club qui a marqué
qui a marqué le championnat de france en
division 1 et est maintenant en division
2 c'est pas le plus grand club de france
on aimerait on a encore beaucoup de
choses à prouver pour arriver à ce
niveau-là on s'inspire des meilleures
on peut avoir en d1 sur le black ou le
flash mais c'est vraiment sur ce compte
en fait c'est un club familial c'est
bien ça alors c'est un club
très clairement quand on voit le staff
qui bossent qui bosse avec moi
aujourd'hui c'est que des anciens des
gars qui qui ont joué contre plus de 15
ans d'ancienneté dans ce club qui ont
tout donné qu'on commençait dans les
plus petites sections et qui se retrouve
maintenant à retransmettre ce qu'ils ont
pu faire
excuses ont pu apprendre auprès tous les
jours qu'ils ont pu passer qui sont plus
qu'ils ont pu passer ici dans le club
est ce que c'est un club qui a quand
même marqué l'histoire par des trophées
par des finales alors on a une on a une
très grosse phase
il ya quelques années où on est monté
jusqu'à 4 le septième club européen à
faire l'eurobowl a joué des finales des
fa cup à faire des finales a acquis
boniface devant des milliers de
personnes à faire des finales de
championnat de france on était dans le
top 4 français d un pendant de
nombreuses années et c'était vraiment
une le club rouler c'était vraiment un
très très bon souvenir et une très belle
expérience vous êtes de saljic ont le
sens de cette période moi c'est alors je
suis nostalgique oui mais
c'est ce que je veux en fait aujourd'hui
pour mes joueurs je veux l'or je vais
leur fabriquer des souvenirs
tout ce que j'ai vécu aujourd'hui je
veux leur donner le double jeu qui
puisse vivre ces choses-là jeu quand on
puisse remporter des trophées est
vraiment créer un groupe est très
clairement des souvenirs qu'ils
oublieront jamais c'était au début des
années 2000 entre 2000 et 2010 à peu
près l'âge d'or si je peux dire détendre
et on va dire ça ouais qui existe comme
ça on a eu on a une dizaine d'années où
on était vraiment vraiment au top
français qu'est-ce qui a fait que le
club est redescendu justement après on a
eu une trouve vraiment dans la montée
des juniors
et qui nous a énormément pénalisés
et derrière c'est vrai qu'on a
énormément travaillé période mathieson
qui est où les robinson qui ont monté le
club à un niveau tel
donc aujourd'hui si les templiers ont eu
cette envie recettes à cette image de
ces rayonnements france s'est
entièrement grâce à eux ils ont moi j'ai
appris grâce à peyras mathieson et
aujourd'hui je retransmets ce que j'ai
appris grâce à lui est ce qu'il ya des
joueurs qui ont vraiment marqué le club
je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
d'américains par exemple qui sont venus
jouer ici on a eu perez mathieson
obligatoires il est resté il est resté
pratiquement 7 8 ans ici il vivait à
l'année ici on et willy robinson qui a
donné qui a donné cet esprit et alix de
fighter derrière on a
incubé comme shelton qui arrivait sur la
fin qui maintenant rayonne au plus haut
niveau européen et
on a eu vraiment des joueurs même des
coachs un paul claudel qui est qui était
un coach avec des va dire des dizaines
des vagues plus d'une trentaine d'années
d'expérience qui a apporté une dimension
et est quelqu'un d'un amoureux du
football et encore aujourd'hui la
manière dont on joue elle a inspiré de
ce que lui il a pu apporter autant pis
c'est quoi votre plus grand rêve pour
les templiers d'elancourt mois claire
clairement cette année je veux qu'on
remporte le championnat d'accord on sait
que c'est compliqué il ya des fortes
équipes fortes équipes en face
chaque match on le fait pour le gagner
forcément donc
tous les matches qu'on va faire cette
saison on va les jouer pour les gagner
et ce qui compte ce que je répète aux
joueurs le plus important c'est de
gagner le dernier match il ya juste il
faut qu'on gagne le dernier match on n'a
pas besoin d'être le plus fort durant la
saison il faut juste gagner le dernier
match pour l'histoire des templiers pour
l'histoire détend bien
alors alix on peut dire que la saison a
parfaitement débuté avec cette première
victoire contre les dragons de paris pas
exactement la saison a bien débuté on
s'en sort vraiment bien on a bien bossé
en début de saison on avait des matches
amicaux qui nous ont permis de voir que
le temps une bonne phase et ça a été
confirmé ce week end
cette équipe elle a vraiment du
potentiel j'ai l'impression cui ouest
équipe a du potentiel en fait c'est un
groupe qui s'est constitué et qui a
continué à rester ensemble pendant le
covin et ils sont très demandeurs et ça
monte en puissance petit à petit et
franchement le sens là en ce moment
c'est une émulsion c'est vraiment en
plus en ce moment est ce qui a été très
dur justement c'est des gardes est
vraiment concentré sur le foot us
pendant le coc vide parce qu'il ya deux
saisons blanches il faut le rappeler a
exactement il y avait deux saisons
blanches on va dire est une ennemie ils
ont été coupées et sont restés un peu
sur leur faim il ya deux ans je suis
arrivé d'ailleurs à ce moment là à la
fin de cette saison et j'ai bien
ressenti en arrivant en prenant mon
poste de coordonnateur défensif cette
année que ils étaient les morts de faim
il attendait que ça donc il a fallu à
l'égard dé continuer à s'entraîner leur
donner la motivation est la mairie
d'elle en cours et notamment le maire
nous a permis de nous entraîner ça c'est
hyper important c'est hyper important il
permet nous entraîner on a respecté les
protocoles et franchement bon on voit le
résultat de ce week-end c'est nickel
c'était pas trop dur en tant que coach
justement de les garder
en haleine ouais très grosse frustration
surtout pour moi en fait parce que
coordinateur défensif bas football
américain en défense et placage et bat
avec les avec les directives impossible
de faire du contact donc on a repris
toutes les bases on a repris toutes les
bases on a repris le déplacement les
positions le stand fois plein de choses
qui les a laissés dans le jargon de
football américain et ensuite de saba
fallait garder la tête haute pour ne pas
dépasser les limites qu'ils étaient
autorisés quoi on sent également très
motivé pour une montée en fin de saison
est ce que dès la préparation physique
vous les avez senti motivé pour a
décroché cette montée franchement dès la
préparation physique on les a accueilli
le premier jour avec notre préparateur
physique qui est julien tanguay abadia
en leur disant que voilà ce qu'ils
allaient faire aujourd'hui
allait leur permettre et c'était le
début le commencement est ce qui allait
leur permettre en fait de performer de
ce nom la saison donc on leur a mis dès
le départ dans la tête que cette
préparation qui a duré plus de deux mois
allez les faire monter en pression et
allait leur donner du résultat et quand
ils ont bien souffert quand ils ont vu
le résultat de 2,2 ce week-end ils sont
du bon bah c'est vrai remet sur la phase
montante et c'est vraiment s'en voulait
les amener à ce niveau là mais c'est pas
fini ça c'est sûr c'est pas fini et on
va continuer cette montée c'est utopique
ou complètement réalisable selon cette
montée elle n'est pas utopique cette
montée elle est déjà dans nos têtes
premièrement
elle est dans nos envies elle est dans
notre travail elle n'est pas utopique
parce que on revient de deux années
blanches on sait pas comment les clubs
se sont entraînés ou pas on sait pas ce
qui se passe mais en tout cas nous on
sait que c'est possible pour nous et on
sait qu'au quotidien on va travailler
pour faire cette montée on a vraiment
que ça en tête en fait dans la khl à
monter on a vu précédemment le club a
énormément d'histoires c'est un club qui
compte dans le paysage du foot us en
france est ce qui est sa place et
forcément en première division bah et
ancien joueur templiers et temps et
enfin fait partie en fait des années
européenne oui le club a une forte
histoire c'est sa place est en 1re
division les aléas ont fait les
générations ont tourné c'est vrai nous
notre génération j'ai 37 ans on a arrêté
un moment donné on a fait à fait de la
transmission il ya eu la formation on va
dire qu'on est passé aussi sur une
société un peu de consommateurs le foot
n'est plus le même qu'avant donc voilà
tout ça de se mettre en place c'est
normal ça prend son temps si ça mais
trois quatre ans à mettre à 34 ans mais
je pense que cette année on est bien
parti pour
être sur cette phase cette dynamique de
montée
[Musique]
m
je suis maintenant à côté de deux
piliers du club jérémy et jordan alors
jérémy pourquoi vous avez choisi les
templiers d'elancourt c'est une histoire
d'amour avec ce club or c'est tout
d'abord une histoire d'amour c'est vrai
je suis pas en général ce club-là mais
j'ai entendu beaucoup d'échos de la
vitrine de ce club c'était pour moi le
club de prestige du 78 c'est ce qui m'a
attiré je voulais augmenter un peu mon
niveau de jeu donc du coup bas la
famille des templiers m'a accueilli les
bras ouverts et c'est vrai que quand
j'ai émis quand j'ai foulé mon premier
pied sur ce terrain là c'était la
révélation quoi même chose pour vous
jordan vous ça fait dix ans que vous
êtes là ouais c'est ça ça fait dix ans
j'ai eu une coupure de quelques années
on va dire
la raison pour laquelle je suis ici bas
déjà c'est la proximité mais ensuite
c'est aussi la réputation du club parce
que il ya dix ans c'était l'un des
meilleurs clubs de france voire même
d'europe ensuite j'ai eu une coupure
pour blessure et aussi pour raisons
personnelles et je suis revenu par
passion et surtout parce que le club
notre slogan c'est we are family et
c'est pas pour rien en fait c'est
vraiment une famille donc voilà je suis
revenu avec les mêmes les mêmes
ambitions et les mêmes envies et qu'est
ce qui fait justement que c'est une
famille vous m'en parlez tous ici a
depuis tout à l'heure qu'est ce qui fait
que c'est une famille finalement à
l'étang pied des recours bah déjà la
première raison c'est parce que c'est
c'est un club je dirais pas que c'est un
petit club mais c'est un club qui a pas
beaucoup de
comment dire de personnel donc on se
sent très proche c'est pas une grosse
grosse structure comme on peut le voir
dans d'autres clubs franciliens et rien
que pour ça ça fait déjà un club
familial mais après derrière il suffit
de passer un an avec nous et on
s'apprécie tous on s'aime tous et c'est
pas que sur le terrain c'est vraiment
aussi en dehors du terrain on va
s'entraider et c'est vraiment ce qui
fait qu'il ya ce lien familial et
tourner ça dort il ya également des
coups durs comme dans chaque club il ya
eu des descentes par exemple il ya eu
des montées
comment comment gère tout ça comment
commence à ger au sein du groupe il ya
toujours des facteurs incontrôlables
actuellement il ya qu vide donc c'est
vrai que ça fait maintenant quatre ans
non c'est quoi c'est le troisième saison
en deuxième division on vise toujours la
première division c'est un fait de jeu
ce qu'a dit jordan c'est vrai c'est que
les templiers c'est we are family on a
toujours eu ce lien quoi qu'il arrive
depuis des décennies et puis on a
toujours les mêmes les mêmes ambitions
c'est de remonter en première division
voilà c'est ce qui nous motive chaque
jour pour venir s'entraîner sur le
terrain et puis maintenant on a plus
qu'à faire nos preuves cette année sur
le terrain pour espérer déjà gagné
championnat et à remonter en première
division jordan lors d'une interview
récente sur tv 78 tu vas parler d'aller
en 1re division voire d'aller en en
europe c'est aussi allées du club à
l'europe oui complètement puisqu'il ya
quelques années c'était c'était une
habitude chez les templiers c'est posez
pas la question ouais voilà c'est
exactement ça a toujours été une
habitude en tout cas à une très belle
époque justement là où on était dans les
premiers premier club français les
premiers clubs de clubs d'europe et
c'est surtout ça qu'on veut qu'on veut
retrouver parce que faut dire la vérité
le club des templiers d'elancourt n'a
rien à faire en d2 on y est depuis un
bon moment on a connu des descentes mais
on est toujours restés soudés pour
remonter et c'est ce qu'on va faire
encore cette année vous avez le
sentiment que vous avez les
infrastructures les coaches les joueurs
pour pouvoir aller injustement un peu
plus haut
chaque année on a toujours eu ce qu'il
nous fallait en fait après celle envies
de chacun qui fait que l'équipe peut
s'améliorer peu montant pendant division
maintenant cette année on s'est vraiment
qu'on a vraiment toutes les clés pour y
arriver il ya plus qu'à montrer le
résultat c'est quoi pour vous il saison
réussie du coup jordan et jérémy c'est
quoi une saison réussie sur le plan
personnel et collectif alors on en parle
assez souvent que ce soit à
l'entraînement ou pendant les matches où
on récemment la faire un stage un petit
stage
de quelques jours pour vraiment
ressouder le groupe
l'objectif club c'est vraiment une
finale de d2 ce qui nous permet de
monter en élite mais après l'objectif de
chaque joueur parce que entre joueurs on
en parle entre nous l'objectif forcément
c'est le titre c'est d'être champion
pareil j'ai jamais accédé à une finale
il même à un titre là maintenant je
pense que chaque joueur qui vient
s'entraîner c'est c'est le titre voilà
on espère tous remonter en d1 parce que
c est ce que c'est la place des
templiers aujourd'hui c'est la première
division mais là maintenant on veut
gagner un titre on veut marquer
l'histoire des templiers c'est une
fierté aussi personnelle de représenter
une ville oui ça c'est sûr de
représenter une ville de replonger de
représenter un sport atypique font pas
faut pas se mentir parce que beaucoup
connais beaucoup savent que voilà il ya
un club de foot de foot américain ici
mais après ils connaissent pas forcément
ce sport c'est pas un sport qui est dans
la culture française donc maintenant à
nous aussi de leur donner envie de
découvrir justement parlez match par les
bons résultats surtout et c'est ce qu'on
va faire cette année
[Musique]
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur les
templiers d'elancourt rendez vous sur
leur site internet leur prochain match
est programmé le 30 janvier prochain sur
le terrain des dockers de nantes
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
l'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tb 78
[Musique]